hey guys you know we always talk about
things that guys
should do tips for this steps for that
but we rarely talk about the things
the important things that men should not
do
people are overly sensitive these days
and so people are scared
to talk about the important issues you
don't want to step on somebody's toes
people are overly sensitive and you
can't
almost say anything anymore because if
you do
they take it personally or they
misunderstand what they're saying and
they
twist what you said and try to use it
against you
where has free speech gone yeah that is
the world that we live in today
but for this video we're gonna talk
about the 10 things men
should not do because if you do it the
consequences
they're going to be bad for you and for
the people around you
let's get to the video
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Music]
now just very quick if it's the first
time that you're here on my channel i'm
daniel and welcome to dla model
lifestyle if you haven't subscribed yet
and please consider it and also click
that notification bell so you won't miss
any of the next videos now let's not
waste any more time let's start with the
first thing
men should stop doing
[Music]
break your promises if you can't keep
your word
then don't make any promises don't say
you'll do something i'll do this i'll do
that i promise you i'll do that
and then you don't do it your yes
should be yes always and your no
should always be no people should know
where they stand with you if you want
good relationships if you want people to
trust you
but you don't keep your word it's not
gonna happen
you know there used to be a time where
men had more honor
they used to say things like my word is
my bond
these days you can't trust anyone what a
sad world
we live in but if you want to stand out
keep your promises be a man of your word
someone people can trust and look up to
[Music]
look away when you greet someone i mean
who does that if you look away while
greeting someone
you've just lost your respect from that
person look the person you're greeting
in the eyes and greet them with respect
if you don't do it properly if you look
away while you're greeting someone
then you're just actually telling them i
don't really respect you
i'm just greeting you out of courtesy
but i don't really care
about you it really is so disrespectful
and it shows that you are a selfish
person that only cares about
yourself
leave your crotch alone it's
really so disrespectful and no i'm not
going to stay in a conversation with you
if you can't leave your crotch alone if
you keep scratching it or adjusting it
it's so distracting and it's just very
offensive i mean
have some self-control man or go to the
toilet and adjust whatever you need to
adjust
if you've got a fungal infection lice or
just dryness or something else
then sort it out get a cream and take
care of it but if it's just a bad habit
then break the habit starting today if
you
scratch down there and adjust the whole
time while you're talking to somebody it
really is
disrespectful some guys do it for this i
don't know this ego
thing like as if touching down there is
going to make you more
manly that's silly
[Music]
never share too much this is especially
true when you meet someone for the first
time
don't over share your life they don't
know you yet
and they don't care about your opinion
about every single thing
in the world especially when it comes to
things like politics
or your sex life or how much money you
earn
especially when you force it on people
get to know them first and how they
view life ask them more questions
get to learn more about them instead of
just talking about yourself the whole
time
you know sometimes when you're when
you're in a group there are these guys
who want to control the conversation
and if you do it you might feel powerful
you might feel that all right i'm in
control everybody listens to me
but in reality you're probably the most
disliked person there
control yourself there's a quote that
says
wise men talk because they have
something to say
fools talk because they just want to say
[Music]
something
stop scrolling down your phone
when someone is talking to you do you
like it when you talk to someone and
they do what i'm doing right now they
don't have eye contact they ignore you
and they just keep on scrolling of
course you don't like it nobody likes it
so stop scrolling down your phone on
social media when someone
is talking to you if you do it you
immediately lose your respect
that that person have for you and it
weakens your relationship with them
if you do it you're just actually
telling them you're not that interesting
i'm
i'm a little bit bored so i'll rather
look at something more interesting
on social media on my phone
[Music]
text or call late at night respect
people's privacy
and their time to rest if someone did
not die
or if it's not really serious then you
can wait
to tell them in the morning if you call
after let's say 9 10 11
then you're just thinking of yourself
and the message you want to tell them
but if you call or text earlier that
evening
or just the next morning then you're
thinking more about
them you're thinking about their needs
instead of
your own and it shows
[Music]
picking your nose what is it these days
with men
just picking their nose in public as if
it's nothing
it's gross not only is it gross it's
also dangerous for you
because as you mine for that gold you
bring viruses
and bacteria into your system with your
dirty fingers
and then you also spread your own around
whatever you touch
all it takes is just to say excuse me
for a few seconds you go to the toilet
the restroom
and you blow your nose you get it all
out it's that simple
so just do it if i see a guy
just going for that gold while i'm
talking to him i make mental note
not ever to greet him again with my hand
just a fist bump
will do
this one is very important never
disrespect your mother your
sister or the woman in your life
[Music]
or abuse her if you hate a woman
some men i don't know they feel manly or
something when they do it
you're not a man you're a coward now a
marriage
is hard work and it needs to come from
both sides to make it work
and yes she will make mistakes because
she's human just like you
we all make mistakes we are not perfect
so she will make mistakes
but then handle it the right way still
treat her with respect
you can tell her hey this is not right
what you did and this and this you can
tell her
but it's not just about what you tell
her is the way
you do it and remember when the time
comes when you're gonna make mistakes
you will you would want her to handle
you the right way as well
a man who doesn't respect his wife
especially in front of other people does
not deserve her
[Music]
never leave the men's room without
washing your hands
i mean come on guys who who does that
i i'm both shocked and surprised every
time i see someone
going straight from the urinal to the
exit not washing their hands
i mean i don't actually know why i have
to
talk about this because it's common
sense and it's just basic
hygiene and there are a lot of guys who
do it
and then you want to go and greet
someone you don't know what they've done
with their hands
maybe we should stop doing that maybe we
should just change greetings to
fist bumps
never settle for just 99
i come from a family who works hard
my dad his dad my grandfather
his dad everybody worked hard and it was
ingrained into us to work hard
but not just to work hard but to give
your best 100
in everything that you do and it's like
more and more guys
start to be more lazy i don't know why i
don't know what it is
procrastination they're just bored maybe
it's the way they grow up i don't know
but as men we should never be okay with
just
doing okay if you do something and you
say ah
it's okay that will not do if you do
something and you say oh
it is good that will not do
you need to do your best at every single
thing you take on
you need to be great be a great dad
a great son a great brother a great
friend
and be a great man and here's the
interesting part
your 100 will always keep growing
why because you will keep growing you
will learn more about life you will
become
wiser and grow in your experience so
you will always be able to do more than
you think
you can but remember it's up to you to
work on yourself
because no one else will do it you are
responsible for your own
life and please remember what i'm
telling you today
always remember to educate not only your
mind but also your heart
because just education without good
values
does not make you a better man now if
you want to improve yourself and become
a better man
then watch this playlist here or this
one from my other channel
and i'll see you there cheers guys
you